what's going on guys happy 2017 that's
right it's January the time of year for
resolutions new gym membership so you
can get that bikini body and really
terrible movies but you're not we here
at screen junkies are always on the
lookout for the next standout January
release the diamond in the coal mine
the next Cloverfield or tremors or taken
all January releases by the way here are
seven movies that we think you should
see this January PS some of these films
were already available in limited
release but this January are going
nationwide right off the bat let's start
with a polarizing director trying to
right the ship talk an M night Shyamalan
we've given M night a lot of grief on
this show but to be fair all of it very
well deserved the twist masters back
with his latest film split which is
actually getting good early reviews and
being held possibly as a return to form
by all the critics don't worry he's not
allowed to touch him James McAvoy who
you know as Professor X from various
x-men films plays a man with 23
different personalities that start
jockeying for dominance inside his head
my name is Edwin o.9 you know with
Shyamalan there's gonna be a twist and
McAvoy is 23 personalities and Jim
Carrey was in the movie the number 23
and Michael Jordan famously wore the
number 23 so the twist is two of his
personalities are Jim Carrey and Michael
Jordan you heard it here first and
probably last a monster calls is a late
2016 release that goes wide this week
now I mistakenly thought it was about a
monster like prank calling people but I
was horribly mistaken and quickly set
straight when I saw the movie the movies
already certified fresh' on Rotten
Tomatoes and it focuses on a boy who's
forced to face a family crisis with the
help of a group like monster voiced by
Liam Neeson what did the Invisible Man
do
nikohl from monster film also stars
rogue ones Felicity Jones and it's
directed by J a Bayona
who's currently directing Jurassic world
2 also a warning I've seen the film so I
just want to let you know bring a tissue
cuz uh make it those waterworks going I
openly wept in the middle of a Chipotle
just thinking about a monster calls
sorry like this also opening wide this
week is hidden figures the true story of
three african-american women who were
instrumental in working with NASA during
the space race of the 1960's every time
we have a chance to get ahead they move
to finishing I need to be in that room
hearing what you hear it's got a great
cast including taraji P Henson Octavia
Spencer Kevin Costner and Kirsten Dunst
and has already been nominated for
multiple Golden Globe and SAG Awards
with some serious Oscar buzz behind it
come Glee let's get to know NASA hasn't
given up on good old-fashioned
brainpower
now I know it's tempting to go out and
see rogue one for the fifth time but why
not spend some of that hard-earned money
on the real Star Wars except this one
doesn't have like you know droids or a
Death Star or like anything else
associated with Star Wars okay it
doesn't have anything to do with Star
Wars but uh come on
mix it up a little also getting a lot of
Oscar buzz is 20th century women written
and directed by Mike Mills and starring
Annette Bening whose performance is
being buzzed about as potential Best
Actress material I just think that you
know having your heart broken this is
tremendous way to learn about the world
betting plays a landlord struggling to
raise her son in the late 1970s with the
help of her building tenants man wish my
landlord would do cool stuff like that
all she does is ask me dumb questions
like where's the rent what's that smell
hey I told you no animals in your
apartment how many people live in there
what was that noise
did you steal someone's mail I was
recently evicted
you know what feel free to leave a note
in the comment section below if I can
crash at your house just say how you can
crash here I'll follow up we were just
talking about some potential Oscar
contenders yeah this movie's not going
to be one of those but it might be a lot
of fun XXX the return of xander cage one
of the 17 films opening this year that
star Vin Diesel that's right VIN is back
and the action franchise that you might
remember listen I can't sell you on this
movie based on prestige Oscar buzz or
really even a promise that it's going to
be good all I can promise you though is
three things
Vin Diesel skateboarding on the side of
a bus then diesel jumping over a car and
motorcycles that are also jet skis what
more could you ask for
speaking of junk that's not very good
for you but just really enjoyable
McDonald's is getting its own movie and
it's not macking me the et rip-off from
the 1980s Michael Keaton stars in the
founder the story of McDonald's founder
Ray Kroc and how he transformed a small
chain of fast-food restaurants into the
24-hour breakfast serving monstrosity
that we have today my brother had a
brilliant idea orders ready in 30
seconds there should be McDonald's
everywhere
franchise franchise franchise founder
opens wide on January 20th and what
better way to spend inauguration day
than by wrapping yourself up in the
story of a business tycoon who rises to
power as he crushes all who oppose him
happy meals for everyone I want to win
and finally Mark Wahlberg is back and
yet another real-life docudrama with
Patriots Day a retelling of the fateful
hours surrounding the Boston Marathon
bombing two bombers we got to find these
guys before they do this is someone else
this is Mark Wahlberg's third time
working with director Peter bird they
teamed up for Deepwater Horizon back in
the fall and previously had worked
together on lone survivor Patriots day
is getting great reviews with Wahlberg
playing another hero based on real-life
events
we're gonna do count them down catch and
kill him all that
somebody at us also you can see Mark
Wahlberg in another starkly real
performance taking on a true story of
one man facing down Decepticons from
outer space and transformers the last
night we've established previously I
have trouble telling real from fake well
there you have it those are the movies
that were excited for coming up what are
you looking forward to is it the latest
Resident Evil and underworld movies or
is it monster trucks and why are you
excited for monster trucks let us know
in the comments section below I want to
know thanks for watching I'm howl
Rudnick hit me up on Twitter bye bye hey
guys did you know that this end card
works with your phone now I know right
click the boxes below to watch more
screen junkies videos and click the
screen junkies logo to subscribe and get
this show honest trailers movie fights
and more